are you excited for Ubisoft for honor
next year do you want more than just the
standard game in a case I'm Tony and
this is your honorable gamespot news
update the for honor collector's edition
comes in a special case containing the
game itself an exclusive lithograph the
official soundtrack and a season pass
but the highlight for sure is a trio of
helmets representing the games three
factions biking night and samurai these
are full metal built to one-third scale
and placed on a slick wouldn't stand
there's no word on whether or not they
can fit on your cat's head but it's
worth noting that you can only get this
version of the game through Ubisoft's
you play store no final pricing has been
announced for honour comes to ps4 xbox
one and pc on februari 14 2017 anyone
who pre-orders the game before the
Valentine's Day launch will get the
legacy battle pack for free which adds
three extra hero outfits to the game
we're expecting plenty more information
and trailers before launch day but if
you want to keep up with all of it
you're already in the right place
you